se trata de una noticia que esperaron
durante años
hice clic en el enlace demostró que las
parejas homosexuales pueden adoptar
niños
estaba dormido así que corría nuestra
habitación y le dije
Despierta Despierta podemos adoptar
niños
Fue como un sueño para nosotros el
universo enviándonos este mensaje pero
en realidad no fue el universo era
nuestro parlamento y todas esas
organizaciones de la sociedad civil
organizaciones de derechos lgbt
legisladores amigables con los
homosexuales
la elección progresista de Taiwán es la
primera en Asia y siete de cada 10
votantes allí apoyan la medida
uno de mis hijos es parte de la
comunidad Así que básicamente tengo una
actitud muy normal hacia esto lo más
importante es que sean felices con su
pareja
personalmente creo que mientras ambas
partes sean financieramente estables
deberían poder adoptar primero el
matrimonio entre personas del mismo sexo
luego un ministro de gobierno
transgénero y ahora los derechos de
adopción Taiwán está años por delante de
sus vecinos regionales en lo que
respecta a los derechos lgbtiq más
siendo el único país de la región que
permite la adopción homoparental
en comparación con muchos países
asiáticos taiwanes más liberal y
democrático y sobre la base de la
Democracia los taiwaneses tienen la
oportunidad de tener una conversación
más abierta sobre diversos temas
para grupos de Derechos Humanos en
Taiwán el largo camino hacia la igualdad
continúa la próxima batalla se centra en
legalizar los tratamientos de fertilidad
para parejas lesbianas